public sénat
arnaud montebourg est l'invité de
preuves par 3 bonsoir et merci d'être
avec nous au chantre de la
démondialisation durant la campagne de
la primaire socialiste vous parcourez la
france depuis quelques semaines la
france de la désindustrialisation pour
françois hollande
l'emploi est bien sûr au coeur des
préoccupations des français qui se
disent par ailleurs déçu un parent par
la tournure actuelle de la campagne
présidentielle nous aborderons ce sujet
tout à l'heure avec samir tounsi de l'
agence france-presse notre partenaire et
puis perrine tarneaud de public sénat
lui succédera et nous parlerons du
printemps des poètes à aragon la rose et
le réséda qui vous inspirent pour votre
mouvement
arnaud montebourg d'abord est-ce que
vous avez obtenu des informations de la
police ou de la justice
après l'agression dont vous avez été
victime l'autre soir dans les rues de
paris avec votre compagne oui d'abord je
veux remercier les forces de l'ordre de
prendre très au sérieux cette enquête
judiciaire la police judiciaire m'a
montré la vidéo surveillance qui avait
enregistré l'ensemble des faits et
contrairement aux insinuations que je
lis parfois ici ou là où finalement nous
aurions monté en épingle et amplifier un
incident qui n'aurait pas été grave ou
qui auraient été sans importance ou sans
conséquence toutes les déclarations que
j'ai pu faire ainsi que audrey pulvar
sur procès-verbal la police judiciaire
sont parfaitement confirmé et
l'agression est parfaitement démontré
dans la façon dont la caméra de
vidéosurveillance a filmé la scène la
question c'est le lien avec le front
national est ce qu'il est établi le côté
jeu en dehors des insultes raciales
antisémites des violences volontaires
jet de verre deux verres que nous avons
essuyé je n'y peux rien si ces militants
scandaient le nom de le pen président
donc il ya bien un militantisme un
engagement politique une présentation
d'un soutien à l'un des candidats
général alain baïges favorisée par
marine le pen selon vos le climat
général de là
libération de la parole raciste est un
problème dans notre pays ça se voit déjà
sur les matchs de foot pas seulement
professionnels mais aussi amateurs mais
là nous avons une scène de rue qui
rappelait les heures sombres de notre
histoire avec l'allusion au qu'il
faudrait chassés de france le mot juden
qui a été crié des insultes nature comme
les graisses ou montebourg va mettre tes
babouche parce que mes origines
algériennes sont connus donc nous avons
affaire à des militants politiques qui
connaissent si son qu'ils nous ont
reconnus les militants politiques donc
vous mettre des militants politiques
cela ils sont effectivement ils sont
identifiés je fais confiance maintenant
à la police si on les voit à visage
découvert sur les vidéos je fais
confiance à la police judiciaire pour
procéder à l'identification des
coupables et de l'interpellation
prochaine je l'espère qu'elle soit être
proche je le souhaite pour le souhaitez
marine le pen justement il a donc lancé
le débat sur la viande halal elle est
suivie par le président candidat pour
qui c'est le premier sujet de
préoccupation des français il l'a dit
est ce que vous diriez à titre personnel
comme françois fillon que l'abattage
rituel ne correspond à plus grand chose
dans le monde moderne
écoutez faire la question de savoir si
l'étourdissement des animaux avant leur
abattage leur consommation est une
préoccupation majeure de la france me
paraît être une manoeuvre grossière et
grotesque de diversion par rapport aux
problèmes considérables qu'aujourd'hui
les français rencontrent leur vie
quotidienne
nous avons perdu sept cent cinquante
mille emplois industriels sur le
territoire en plus fait un tour comment
j'ai fait un tour de france oui c'est un
tour de france de la désolation des
industriels de la viande halal nous
avons perdu 900 usine en trois ans qui
ont fermé dans notre pays et vous avez
un président de la république qui refuse
de faire la moindre proposition de
stratégie de sortie de crise et qui
préfèrent amuser la galerie avec des
histoires d'étourdissement d'agneau et
de moutons qui je le rappelle relève de
rites religieux qui ne regarde pas
l'état l'état a pour mission de garantir
la liberté de l'exercice des cultes
c'est ça le sens du principe de laïcité
que françois hollande souhaite inscrire
dans la constitution c'est une de ses
propositions pour qu' il n'y a pas d'âge
errance dans l'exercice des cultes
chacun a sa religion les mormons les
couacs heures les adventistes et
protestants les bouddhistes les juifs
les chrétiens les catholiques les
protestants
peu importe les musulmans peu importe
ils ont le droit de vivre tranquillement
dans la sphère privée
conformément à leurs rites et l'état
doit assurer le vivre ensemble car nous
sommes un des seuls pays occidentaux au
monde à avoir 5 millions de personnes se
rattachant la culture musulmane et 5
millions c'est beaucoup
donc nous avons la république garantit
la liberté mon cul et la non-ingérence
ce débat créé un certain malaise au sein
de la majorité il ya beaucoup de voix
qui s'élèvent au sein même de l'ump vous
pensez que nicolas sarkozy donc fait
fausse route
d'abord je crois que le premier devrait
retirer ses propos parce que cela ne
relève pas de sa mission que de dire ce
qui est bon ou mauvais dans les rites
religieux ma fille c'est comme si c'est
à titre personnel mais il n'y est pas il
n'accorde expression personnelle il est
le premier ministre de la france
hormis le chef du gouvernement au
président candidat je crois que ce n'est
pas la première préoccupation des
français d'autant que la semaine d'avant
il était allé à rungis pour expliquer
qu'il ya aucun problème dont emmanuel
todd que vous appréciez j'imagine un jeu
sociologues géographes il estime qu'il y
a deux candidats d'extrême droite en
france dont 1 soutenue par l'allemagne
est-ce qu'il va trop loin dans son
appréciation des choses je crois qu'il a
un raccourci qui résume finalement assez
bien la situation c'est que la course
que nicolas sarkozy est en train de
faire derrière madame le pen fait que
finalement madame le pen est la
directrice de campagne de nicolas
sarkozy elle fixe les thèmes fixer
l'agenda les questions et monsieur
sarkozy se précipitent
car ils cherchent aujourd'hui à occuper
l'espace peut-être laissé vacant dans
quelques jours par madame le pen si elle
n'a pas signé cet ennemi sur l'absence
de marie noëlle sur l'opération sur le
terrain
la pression des dirigeants de l'ump
considérable pour empêcher les maires
qui traditionnellement donné leur
signature à madame le pen de le faire ah
oui et par exemple un bon faudrait par
exemple
ah oui est ce qu'il faudrait donc un
geste d
des maires socialistes par exemple pour
permettre je voudrais d'abord vous dire
pourquoi madame le pen risque n'avoir
pas ses signatures à cause d'elle même
car elle a sur son flanc droit car elle
a une extrême droite derrière derrière
l'extrême droite madame le pen y'a une
autre extrême droite car le plus dur
monsieur carl lang qui a déjà quelques
400 signatures lui le directeur de
campagne de son père jean marie le pen
qui a stérilisé 380 signatures pour
empêcher madame le pen de se présenter
ils ont décidé en interne d'abattre
marine le pen loukili relais maternel et
entend dénoncer que madame le pen ne
rassemble pas son camp ce que son père
réussissait à faire et c'est une des
raisons pour lesquelles les guérillas
entre faction d'extrême droite
aujourd'hui qui sévissent sur le
territoire français est au tour de
madame le pen a pour conséquence que
madame le pen risque par son incapacité
à faire ce que son père réussit ses
affaires de ne pas pouvoir les pressions
de l'ump sur ces maires pour qu'ils n'y
a pas de signature alors ce serait une
telle déflagration l'absence de marine
le pen un dans la compétition
présidentielle arnaud montbourg
montebourg il faudrait t'il que les
maires socialistes d'honneur parrainage
nous ne sommes pas la roue de secours de
l'extrémisme que madame le pen rassemble
son camp il soit capable finalement de
retrouver les signatures que son père
avait cessé sa tâche mais elle n'en est
pas capable et c'est la raison de son
propre échec
autre sujet en gala merkel en soutenant
nicolas sarkozy rend elle selon vous ce
service à françois hollande
le pacte le fameux pacte des dirigeants
conservateurs européens a été démentie
est ce que ce n'est pas finalement cette
hypothèse cette rumeur lancée par le chp
eagle ou cette information une aubaine
pour le candidat que vous soutenez
d'abord que le groupe des conservateurs
de l'union européenne décide de se
coaliser contre finalement les
propositions de françois hollande de
renégociation du traité punitifs sur la
question budgétaire c'est-à-dire le
traité osterrieth r1
vous avez une droit des traités oui vous
avez une droite européenne de
l'austérité vous avez une gauche
européenne de la croissance et c'est ce
refus parce que la croissance se décrète
pas retraité à c'est une stratégie
économique refuse d'accepter madame
merkel
c'est tout le débat d'avion entre la
droite et la gauche allemande nous avons
signé un texte avec le spd allemand nous
parti socialiste français qui propose un
autre chemin une autre alternative
notamment la remontée des salaires en
allemagne des salaires minima qui
n'existe pas il n'y a pas de ce mal mais
également des normes sociales minimales
sur les prestations sociales assurance à
la vie retrait de santé dans tous les
pays une initiation on est d'accord du
traité se poser faut pas que vous aimez
vous voyez bien akossi watts pme veulent
empêcher une go de réussite dont 1
à la une i vtec à pitre
m
or en europe
elle me pique aaron de pâma les droites
europe or le candidat attentes puisque
comme cela nous pourrons nous tous je
les ai pas ils en veulent aux tic
4 vous parlez des sociaux démocrates
allemands en travaillé cette année
qu'ils ont été très surpris par la
position de françois de taxer à hauteur
de 75%
les très riches pas vous jouez papiers
attendent à la voile à la fois ce sont
les patrons du cac 40 comme pour les
footballeurs d'abord ils viendront parce
que c'est particulièrement injuste que
finalement l'ultra minorité d'ultra
riches qui a fait fortune pendant la
crise sur les décombres de la misère des
autres ne se participent pas à l'effort
de restauration des finances publiques
les mêmes problèmes de flex et pas eu
les actifs
françois hollande a reconnu que ça ne
m'allait pas faire rentrer de l'argent
dans les caisses de lait pain c'est
toujours ça de pris ça de moins que le
peureux il a parlé d'un exemple
patriotique mais c'est nécessaire qui
est des exemples patriotique et j'ai
envie de vous dire dans le faire un
exemple dans la lah l'histoire des états
unis d'amérique qui dirait eu des taux
beaucoup plus élevé je crois 80% à
l'époque du président roosevelt on le
sait toujours là mais j'étais le
l'emblème de ma campagne des primeurs ce
soir il y avait pas mal d'exemption à
l'époque paraît-il un oui mais c'était
nécessaire parce que il s'agissait de
rétablir les comptes publics prises pour
retenir les riches en france mais qui va
payer à leur place d'abord les riches
mais pas chez moi ils ont le devoir de
respecter leur patrie tu as comme son
passeport français partent déjà eu des
dossiers se constitue par exemple
aujourd'hui dans les cabinets
d'ailleurs monsieur gossio s'ils veulent
partir qu'il parte mais et qui paient
leur place mais s'ils veulent partir
qu'il parte mais nous leur demanderons
des comptes car on reste français ça
s'appelle l'évasion fiscale vous pensez
que nous allons rester inerte devant les
évadés fiscaux
d'ailleurs je vais vous dire si vous
pensez que à baisser l'impôt fait
revenir les riches qui était la tragi
monsieur sarkozy vous vous mettez le
doigt ganté ça les fait partir aussi je
vais vous dire où est passé monsieur
johnny halliday qui avait dit grâce à
nicolas sarkozy je vais rentrer en
france
il est toujours à gstaad en suisse
considéré comme un évadé fiscal et il
n'a fait l'objet d'aucune inquiétude de
la part des services fiscaux
je voudrais que monsieur johnny halliday
rentrer même si l'impôt sont plus
élevées car il pourrait montrer
actuellement il aime son pays est ce que
c'est une mesure symbole patriotique
donc pour reprendre le mot de françois
hollande
destiné à mieux faire passer
l'augmentation des impôts qui va frapper
tous les français demain je vous pose la
question
arnaud montebourg est-ce que vous par
exemple en saône et loire vous avez su
convaincre les habitants qu'il fallait
augmenter les impôts bas je suis les
convainque s'est surtout montré que ça
vous l'avez fait en tous les cas si nous
voulions avoir un minimum de solidarité
notamment sur la dépendance était normal
que cet effort soit demandé quand est ce
qu'il faut dire aux français aussi
mais c'est ce qu'a dit françois hollande
il a exposé dans son discours je crois
de dijon oui qu'il était nécessaire que
la dépendance la dépendant
l'indépendance et le soient financées
par la solidarité donc par un
prélèvement
pourquoi c'est normal dès lors qu' un
effort de solidarité supplémentaire
qu'on demande un effort supplémentaire à
tous surtout pour les millions de
familles qui sont aujourd'hui dans l'
angoisse ça ne concerne pas ça la
dépendance vous le savez bien c'est un
commencement de la retraite à 60 ans
pour ceux qui pourront pas retirer là
aussi cela aussi le plan est financé
il n'y aura pas d'effort sociales
supplémentaires sans effort fiscal
complémentaire
c'est normal mais il suffit de
le dire de le clarifier c'est le cas et
surtout je crois que les français sont
prêts à ça dès lors qu'il ya un plus
pour les normal qu'ils participent à cet
effort commun ce qui serait injuste ce
serait de faire payer le prix de la
crise les dettes accumulées par le
sarkozysme qui sont himalayenne par les
classes maillon classes populaires là
pour le coup je bouge bon excusez moi je
me défends parce que vous empêcher de
terminer mes phrases mais s'agissant de
duperie de la crise et de la dette
c'est la taxation sur les transactions
financières une recette de 200 milliards
au plan européen qui nous permettra de
rembourser très facilement le prix de ce
qu'a coûté les plans de sauvetage et de
renflouement de la grippe a répondu ne
fait pas la différence entre les patrons
du cac 40 qui sont effectivement enrichi
puisque leur rémunération a fortement
progressé
et puis les footballeurs non non lieu
d'ailleurs quel problème pour le
football les clubs s'adapte alors
qu'ailleurs richert on peut demander à
monsieur anelka qui gagne 240000 euros
par semaine dans un club de chine
d'aimer son pays aussi comme vous et moi
peut-être oui ce n'est pas excessif que
lui demander ça et bien comme il aime
son pays qui parlent une langue
française châtié 1 qu'il respecte les
couleurs qu'ils chantent la marseillaise
sur les terrains les pelouse
eh bien il paiera plus d'impôts voilà je
le lui annonce avec d'autres socialistes
et ce sera un grand bien pour la patrie
mais c'est bien lui et tous les autres
en short un football à la halle et samir
tounsi de l' agence france-presse va
nous rejoindre mais avant cela arnaud
montebourg on va donc vous suivre dans
ce tour de france
hélas de la désindustrialisation vous
étiez d'ailleurs en côte de rier auprès
des salariés du laboratoire fournier
dont trajan parra vote dans le grand
laboratoire américain leur emploi est
menacé alors que le groupe américain se
régale boucle bien on vous a vu aussi
auprès des lejaby mais coiffé sur le
poteau d'un par nicolas sarkozy
notamment à yssingeaux mais il ya
d'autres unités de ce fabricant de
lingerie en france sandra cerqueira
en fait partie toujours sur la route
arnaud montebourg candidat à la primaire
socialiste il sillonnait déjà l'hexagone
avec sa caravane
aujourd'hui il est mandaté par françois
hollande pour effectuer un tour de
france des usines qui souffrent c'est
ainsi qu'il a trouvé sa place dans la
campagne
un déplacement par semaine avec à chaque
fois le même message défendre le made in
france défendre aussi son candidat car
le sort des ouvriers en lutte est au
coeur de la présidentielle il est il est
un petit instrument dans leurs caisses
que dirige françois hollande je vais pas
tu ne peut-être pas un piccolo médisants
une flûte traversière le gros de la
mélodie et quand même joué par des gens
comme michel sapin comme manuel base
comme pierre moscovici qui sont les
dirigeants principaux de la campagne de
françois hollande et qui eux entonne le
refrain de la rigueur de gauche à porter
la bonne parole de françois hollande est
une chose trouver des repreneurs en est
une autre
surtout quand l'ump jouent la
concurrence à yssingeaux laurent
wauquiez devant ce arnaud montebourg un
échec pour le ps un mois plus tard c'est
l'acte 2 et le vainqueur cette fois
c'est lui
il réussit le sauvetage du site lejaby
de bourg-en-bresse et d'une cinquantaine
de salariés
la repreneuse assia hiridjee refuse
d'entrer dans des considérations
politiques et se contentent d'assurer
que tout a été fait pour qu'elle ne
baisse pas les bras
il ya des jours où c'était j'étais un
peu découragé ses côtés arrivera jamais
mais il a été au quotidien au quotidien
il a été présent il me disait toujours
maintenant vous allez voir assia vous
vous y arriverez vous y arriverez en vo
trouvera une usine
vous ferez votre projet votre
fabrication française
les syndicats déplorent de ne pas avoir
été associé à ce qu'ils appellent une
reprise politique
une reprise qui permet à arnaud
montebourg de peaufiner son rôle de
monsieur économie de françois hollande
peut-être de futurs minutes voilà
samir tome c'est de l' agence france
presse ne va rejoindre en faire sa
meilleure première question laurent
wauquiez autour des soutes des sites
industriels en difficulté il va donner
un peu osé d'abord on ne fait pas la
cour dans sa démarche je pense je
considère que la désindustrialisation la
réindustrialisation ne paie est une
cause nationale et que nous aurons
besoin de tout le monde donc si monsieur
wauquiez à des solutions surtout pour
une usine qui se trouve à 800 m de ses
bureaux qu'il n'avait jamais été visités
j'étais le premier envoyé par françois
hollande pour voir ces ouvrières qui
scandaient fabriqué en france avec leur
hymne lee
des symboles victimes de la
mondialisation en france ces femmes qui
avaient travaillé toute leur vie payés
au smic qu'on jetait comme ça sans
personne ne s'en occupe
il y avait là une raison bouleversé la
france parce qu'il y avait là une
violence inhumaine cfrn la solution de
reprise qui a été obtenu face à la cgt
qui a déclaré que la solution était
solide
je leur fais confiance de même que tu as
many s'agit d'affronter entrepreneurs
fournisseurs de lv1 je crois que sur le
terrain ça fonctionne d'autant mieux je
m'en réjouis
tant mieux tant mieux tant mieux il ya
encore trois sites lejaby a le secret
mais des solutions elles gardent brieuc
est ce qu'il ya des solutions on vient
sans trouver une pour bourque la
stratégie de made in france de madame
assia érigé qui est une ancienne
créatrice de princesse tam tam et qui a
inventé une nouvelle marque made in
france monette et l'hommage doit lui
être rendus car elle a décidé de
reconquérir le textile français dans la
lingerie qui a été complètement décimée
par l'entrée sans contrepartie ni
condition de la chine dans
l'organisation mondiale du commerce et
son arrivée sur le marché européen a
détruit des centaines de milliers
d'emplois et partout dans nos
territoires dans nos régions
vous voyez les petites unités de 22 30
qui disparaissent sans que personne ne
s'en occupe
eh bien ma la mairie j'ai décidé de
remonter les petites unités donc
j'espère qu'elle va réussir un et
qu'elle pourrait en créer d'autres
et j'espère aussi pour les anciennes
ouvrières de lejaby qu'elles
retrouveront du travail les
mécaniciennes audois de noël les habits
en tunisie elle gagne un peu plus de 200
euros par mois
elles se disent combler très heureuse
comme jamais certes mais nous nous avons
une france qui est en chute libre sur le
plan industriel avec une zone rouge
un pays qui ne produit plus est dans la
main de pays qui eux continuent à
produire
je n'ai pas envie que la france
ressemble un magnifique musée avec
littoral disneyland et des stations de
ski
un fantastique hotel resort and spa 1
nous méritons mieux on sent que vous
êtes très à l'aise dans ce tour de
france d1 de désindustrialisation je
suis malheureux de voir ce que je
constate mais vous avez entendu dans le
reportage ce proche de jean luc
mélenchon qui dit que vous êtes dans
leurs caisses de françois hollande
une flûte traversière qui j'aurai une
petite musique de gauche par rapport aux
grosses caisses de la rigueur de gauche
est-ce que ce que vous a l'impression
que c'est le rapport actuel de force
qu'il ya le rapport de force actuel
qu'il ya dans l'équipe de françois
hollande
ben je ne crois pas parce que le
discours de françois hollande les
orientations de campagne sont le fruit
d'un accord politique entre lui même et
les propositions que j'ai faites visant
d'ailleurs à contraindre les excès de la
finance a engagé un mouvement de
relocalisation sur le territoire qui est
une des composantes de ma
démondialisation qui n'est pas la mienne
des gens mais qui est un mouvement
d'idées qui a beaucoup progressé dans
les têtes en france
d'ailleurs j'étais hier à nancy où
françois hollande m'a demandé de parler
juste avant lui c'était un honneur
reprenant lui-même la parole derrière
moi les discours étaient assez
semblables donc nous voyons bien qu'il y
a je crois un centre de gravité de la
campagne de françois hollande qui est au
coeur de toutes les gauches et de
l'ensemble des gauches et de leur
sensibilité aller beaucoup plus loin
dans votre campagne dans votre propre
campagne en septembre ou au quiz
aujourd'hui de la mise sous tutelle des
banques
quid de la démondialisation nous avons
tout de même un candidat qui est pour
pour le libre échange et du
protectionnisme du protectionnisme qui
s'appelle a démandé je pense que vous
n'avez pas lu le programme de françois
hollande
je vous lis très gentiment il ya des
propositions visant à protéger contre la
concurrence déloyale d'un diagramme que
j'ai lu comme vous ou vous vous avez été
vous avez pu tenir la peur mais c'est ce
que je suis en train de vous dire
d'abord un mouvement de relocalisation
en rappelant les entreprises françaises
à leurs obligations patriotique
exactement ce que fait monsieur obama en
amérique du nord
ce que fait madame rousseff au brésil
mal à mme kirchner
au brésil c'est à dire où on utilise la
fiscalité les marchés publics la
commande publique
les taxes sur les produits déloyaux la
taxe carbone extérieure par exemple et
beaucoup d'autres leviers qui sont entre
les mains des états pour nous protéger
contre la concurrence déloyale
extra-européenne extérieurs à l'union
européenne un mouvement de
relocalisation ça veut dire qu'on va
convoquer les multinationales on va leur
demande
et de relocaliser leurs activités sur le
territoire national quand elle souhaite
fabriquer pour la france à ce propos il
ya une question à la mode dans cette
campagne je ne vous ai pas encore
entendu répondre qu'est ce que vous
préférez une usine renault où une usine
d'une marque française à l'étranger où
une usine toyota ou d'une marque
étrangère qui ouvre en france je veux
les deux mon capitaine
c'est un peu facile comme ben c'est pas
facile parce que la stratégie low cost
qui a choisi monsieur carlos ghosn est
une grave erreur car à force de vouloir
diminuer les coûts vous finissez par
détruire votre outil industriel national
et la marque au losange est aujourd'hui
la seule marque française avec seulement
30 % de composants fabriqués en france
donc vous êtes en train peut-être de
sauver trop temporairement ou
provisoirement la trésorerie de renault
mais en vérité vous avez détruit toute
votre base industrielle donc vous êtes
une sorte d' usine offshore qui va
vendre des voitures comme des petits
pains loccoz pas cher et qui vont être
concurrencé par des pays encore plus
émergents qui auront des coûts encore
sur des technologies totalement banal
donc c'est pour moi une stratégie
suicidaire pour la fin de renault la
crainte vous je pose la stratégie jour
qui est un pays qu du triel sa base
industrielle ans et agathe et 100
l'alliance comme je retourne pas être le
manic 5 études eu cette affaire n'ait
pas de conséquences sur la destruction
éventuel d'emploi sur notre territoire
c'est très bien de vouloir attirer
l'attention de bellissen boursiers mais
vous savez eux
vous connaissez la première inscription
c'est quoi les licenciements boursiers
selon le figaro de ce matin c'est 2 9%
alors que les les fins de cdd et
d'intérim c'est un tiers des
inscriptions à pôle emploi
voilà est-ce que quelques que faire pour
lutter contre ce n est qu après le
quartier précarité pas avoir une
approche statistique du chômage parce
que pour moi un chômeur et vaut un autre
show bien sûr donc tous les chômeurs qui
aurait pu voir leurs emplois maintenus
doivent être on doit à tout prix par les
moyens de la puissance publique éviter
qu'ils le deviennent chômeurs donc je
vais pas faire une arithmétique delà du
chômage et de la douleur
comparées pour moi quand il ya des
emplois qu'on peut préserver parce que
l'entreprise gagne de l'argent il faut
les préserver on a déjà perdu dans la
crise toutes les entreprises qui
faisaient faillite parce qu'elles
gagnaient plus d'argent et qu'elle on
perdait mais maintenant on ferme des
entreprises qui en gagnent alors qu'est
ce qui va nous rester finalement à il
faut l'interdire ça c'est pas que vous
allez en interne vous voulez vous
annoncer des mesures draconiennes oui
mais je vous explique pourquoi c'est
déjà interdit dans la loi aujourd'hui un
licenciement qui n'a pas de cause réelle
et sérieuse sur le plan économique est
interdite le problème c'est qu'il
intervient quand les licenciements à
cayeux que la personne est déjà sur le
mans ce serait d'anticiper et de les
interdire d'interdire les six cadets en
d2 cause qu'on décide et deux cours
d'appel la cour d'appel de paris qu'on
appelle de reims qui ont décidé de
permettre aux organisations
représentatives du personnel ne suce pas
quand manifestement l'entreprise gagne
de l'argent voilà on a su la décision de
la cour de cassation été reportée de
quelques jours sur ce sujet j'ai parlé
hier vous avez parlé hier
de dirigisme pendant tout cas très
récemment vous avez parlé de dirigisme
alors après le protectionnisme dit le
dirigisme là aussi qu'est ce je teste
qu'est ce que c'est concrètement ça veut
dire ce que ça veut dire
il est parti en 2012 on a vu un état qui
étaient incapables d'empêcher les
fermetures de deux grands mais il a été
incapable parce qu'il sait pourquoi ils
ont été incapables parce qu'on a vendu
l'acier d'arcelor qui appartenait aux
européens particulièrement la france à
mittal dont le centre qu'est ce que ça
veut dire le diriger 5 janvier
enfin je l'avais jouée à londres si vous
menez 6 3 sur la question est ce que je
peux répondre à des gérants votre
question par la réponse quand même c'est
que je les sais pas expliquer et vous me
reposez la même question alors c'est
très simple qu'est ce que les quels sont
les pays qui aujourd'hui ont réussi à
survivre dans la crise qui ne se sont
pas écroulés comme la france est en
train de s'écrouler
c'est intéressant d'observer ces ceux
qui ont fusionné les intérêts publics et
les ambitions privé les intérêts privés
les intérêts publics et se sont associés
pour les faire vivre qui ont utilisé
leur monnaie une contrôler les
frontières limiter la circulation des
capitaux
organiser des protections données
d'aider des déductions fiscales
utilisez la commande publique pour
favoriser telle entreprise grecque
s'élevait ce que font tous les pays qui
aujourd'hui ont décidé de faire de la
politique économique et industrielle
voilà est ce que les européens une serre
de manière sauf l'allemagne et les
italiens un peu sur les pays qui ont le
mieux résisté sert ceux qui n'ont pas
piraté pied tout pour l'argent dans le
court terme
elle laissait fait penser qu'il pays une
pl france est un pays qui a adopté le
modèle libéral financier sans l'avoir
jamais délibérément parmi ceux qui se
sont le moins le mois écoulé je pense
qu'il y a par exemple tous les pays
d'amérique du sud la chine est l'exemple
même de la fusion du public et du privé
le
l'allemagne d'une certaine manière a su
le travail et faire travailler le public
et le privé et les états unis ont réussi
ça aussi également alors pourquoi ces
mesures doivent être prises parce que
sinon nous allons nous écrouler nous
allons perdre notre base avec
l'allemagne a surtout baisser le coût du
travail vous le savez vous ne remettez
sur la sphère du coût du travail que
toutes les économies civilité et même
des membres du gouvernement disent qu'à
pas entre la france et la main une
différence de coût du travail
tout lui même sur le luff le déclare
voilà dans tous les journaux un peu
sérieux certes ceux qui savent pas
prendre par la propagande de monsieur
sarkozy
tout le monde reconnaît qu a pas d'écart
de coût du travail il y a juste 15 ans
vingt ans d'investissements dans la
recherche développement remontée en
gamme dans la qualité et une stratégie
de répartition avec les pays hors zone
euro qui sont voisins qui sont les
anciens pays de l'est où on fait sous
traiter la met au garde les fonctions et
grandes fonctions de production et
d'assemblage victoire un dirigisme
dernière question c'est la politique
voyez c'est ça le dirigisme c'est que
l'état se met à diriger le pays parce
que l'économie elle même est incapable
de se sauver elle en est incapable
c'est ça que je voulais bien monsieur
vous avez vous avez sur votre gauche un
candidat qui semble mieux enfin avoir
plus l'attention des ouvriers
l'électorat populaire que vous c'est
jean luc mélenchon qui vient de parler
qui dit qui est d'accueil a de nouveau
refusé de participer à un gouvernement
hollandais ou qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire
j'ai pensé sur le coup que ça serait
plutôt une de vos expressions pendant la
campagne de la primaire
vous connaissez ce n'était pas mon
expression parce que je respecte les
personnes mais l'expression hollande
répond c'est à dire j'ai sous-entend que
si force quand hollande gagne l'élection
présidentielle sa priorité sera de
ramener le déficit public à 3 % en 2013
et
0 % à l'horizon 2017 est ce que vous
pensez que vous êtes à l'aise avec cet
objectif
pour les mecs les concessions et les
conséquences sociales qui pourrait
entraîner d'abord quel est l'objectif
désendetter le pays
oui si vous passez votre temps à
rembourser les dettes
oui on a des enfants je peux pas
terminer que c'est compatible avec la
politique industrielle que vouloir une
france
je reprends été bien ça me fait un
projet et vous recevez vos dettes vous
avez tous les autres pays qui abritent
comment il ya deux manières en monétise
c'est à dire je faisais bien ce que font
les anglais